hello and uh what a weekend we've had
with uh storm B bet and and all the
flooding that happened in the district
and around the county uh I'd just like
to thank everybody who all our staff and
all the emergency services that work
really had uh over the weekend and and
commiserations to any residents that
have been affected by the flooding today
we are filming from uh
barow uh given Halloween is coming we
are at the at Village pumpkins where you
can pick your own pumpkins to carve for
the spooky season we have some amazing
attractions right across our district
whatever the time of year so make sure
you take a look at the calendar on our
website and the social media for
updates the residence magazine the news
will also be out next month with a
packed what's on guide and ideas on
where to shop local this Christmas and
this will be getting to you soon our
council plan is now available to view on
the website will also be some
information about it in the news this
plan sets out what we're hoping to
deliver over the next four years we want
Northeast Arisha to be a place where
people can live comfortably and enjoy
our beautiful
District in my last briefing to you I
spoke about what we are doing to tattle
antisocial behavior in the district
there's a further update on the West
Handley situation I can report that we
have been successful in taking out
personal injunction against those
involved hopefully this demonstrates
that we won't tolerate antisocial
behavior in the district on a happier
note we secured some external funding
for the safer streets funding and UK
shared Prosperity funding of 190,000
which we are using to upgrade the skate
park in kiler Mar which will be a face
rate facility on the subject of sport I
visited eckington killer Marsh Leisure
centers a couple of weeks ago and I was
amazed how busy eckington pool and Jim
were at 9:00 in the morning the new
facilities at killer Marsh are Top Notch
and I would recommend that people go and
have a look for themselves and make
their own mind up I'm delighted that our
Leisure centers in dronfield and
eckington have achieved swim englands
water well-being accreditation this puts
them in an elite group of facilities
which are Champion by for their
accessibility and inclusivity for their
members particularly supporting those
using the services of the long-term
health conditions we have recently held
a competition for local schools to help
us name some of our new bin laes I've
got to say some of the suggestions were
brilliant a lot better than I could have
come up with what do you reckon to some
of these waste
wizard umpty dumpy Mission bin possible
binderella Dan the trash
can Peter Shredder
and last but not least my personal
favorite trash Gordon thanks to all
those schools that took part and well
done just to finish as I mentioned at
the start of my briefing Halloween is
just a few days away with that in mind
I'd like to point out that on on our
website are some great Penny saving
eco-friendly ideas from creating your
own costume to cutting down on party
waste the website is also the place to
go and find out about all all the great
activities taking place for youngsters
at our Leisure centers during October
halftime whatever you do have a safe and
happy Halloween and bonfire night and I
look forward to sharing your updates
with you soon thanks for listening thank
you